خيار جديد للهروب من الحرب العالمية الثالثة
وهو اغتيال بوتين
وقد وضع هذا القرار ضمن
اجتماع امريكي،
فهل يعي الأمريكان هذا الشيء الذي
قد يقدمون على فعله؟
هل كل هذا بسبب قلقهم من استخدام
بوتين للقنبلة النووية الحرارية؟
مقتل واحد من أهم جنرالات بوتين،
والناتو يقول إن الأيام القادمة
ستكون سيئة جدا بالنسبة لأوكرانيا..
وكييف تقول الحلف ضعيف ومشوش!
أوليس هذا هو الحلف الذي أردتم الانضمام إليه؟،
والرئيس الأوكراني يعبر عن غضبه
بسبب رفض الناتو إعلان منطقة حظر جوي
في الأجواء الأوكرانية،
بينما كييف تستعيد بعض المدن والمواقع
التي فقدتها خلال الأيام الأولى للحرب،
والمعارك مستمرة...
مسؤول أوروبي:
روسيا مستعدة لاستخدام قنبلة نووية حرارية
في حربها على أوكرانيا،
بينما الأمين العام للناتو يحذر
الأيام القادمة ستكون سيئة بالنسبة لأوكرانيا..
مخاوف أمريكية من ردة فعل بوتين
تجاه اتساع العقوبات
فالبيت الأبيض لا يعلم ما الذي يخطط له
الدب الروسي،
فقد يكثف العمليات العسكرية في
أوكرانيا بشكل جنوني ما قد
يجعل ضحاياه الكثير والكثير
من المدن والمدنيين .. أو قد يفكر في
هجوم سيبرأني عبر الهاكرز لاختراق
النظام المالي الأمريكي، أو قد يلجأ
بوتين للمزيد من التهديدات النووية
وهنا ستكون كارثة عالمية
أو قد تنقل موسكو حربها إلى ما وراء أوكرانيا..
مع توقع أيضا من إدارة بايدن أن بوتين
لن يجازف بالقيام بأي من الأمور المقترحة
السابقة فقد تؤدي أي خسارة إلى تهديد
سيطرته على السلطة..
قصف أوكراني على قاعدة للمظليين
الروس شمال كييف..
والجيش الأوكراني يستعيد السيطرة على مطار
كولباكينو، في نيكولاييف،
السيناتور الأمريكي غراهام، يدعو
إلى اغتيال رئيس روسيا فلاديمير بوتين،
وقال إن اغتياله سيكون هو الحل للأزمة الحالية،
من جانبه الكرملين رد وقال:
خلال توترات الحروب لا يستطيع
الجميع المحافظة على صحتهم وسلامتهم العقلية،،
بينما طالبت سفارة روسيا في أمريكا البيت الأبيض
بتفسير رسمي لتصريحات غراهام
كما طالبت بإدانة قوية لتلك التصريحات الإجرامية،
حد وصف السفارة الروسية،
بوتين يخسر أحد أهم رجالاته العسكرية،
الجنرال(أندريه سوخوفيتسكي٤٧ عام)
كان أحد المقربين من بوتين،
وكان نائبا لقائد جيش الأسلحة
في المنظمة العسكرية المركزية،
اعتبره الإعلام الروسي أهم الجنود والضباط
في حرب أوكرانيا،
وقتل خلال الأسبوع الأول من الغزو،،
بينما أعلن الكرملين عن فقدانه حوالي
٥٠٠ من جنوده في حربهم ضد أوكرانيا..
تزامن ذلك مع إعلان القوات الروسية دخولها
لمناطق في العاصمة كييف،
الرئيس الأوكراني:
سنطلب من مواطنينا العودة إلى بلادهم
في الوقت القريب،
تصريحات الناتو كانت ضعيفة ومشوشة،
إنهم يعطون الضوء الأخضر لمزيد من الجرائم،،،
فلماذا لا يعلنون منطقة حظر جوي فوق أوكرانيا..
(ظهور زيلينسكي أمام مجلس الشيوخ الأمريكي)
أشار الرئيس الأوكراني، فولوديمير زيلينسكي،
إلى أن "الولايات المتحدة والاتحاد الأوروبي
موحدان من أجل دعم استقلال أوكرانيا
وسيادتها على أراضيها"،
لافتاً إلى أنه أجرى اتصالين مع الرئيسين الفرنسي،
إيمانويل ماكرون، والبولندي، أندجي دودا مردفاً
: "أقدرهما بلا حدود".
"هناك قرارات بدعمنا بعشرات المليارات
من الدولارات لإعادة إعمار أوكرانيا"
زيلينسكي: الجيش الروسي
لم يستطع تحقيق أهدافه والقوات الأوكرانية
تسيطر على كل الاتجاهات
وشدد زيلينسكي على أن "الجيش الروسي
لم يستطع تحقيق أهدافه ولكنه خسر
عشرة آلاف جندي معظمهم صغار"،
موضحاً أن "القوات الأوكرانية تسيطر
على كل الاتجاهات وتحارب العدو في خاركيف،
والقوات الروسية دخلت إلى بعض المواقع للأسف،
ولكن هذا الوضع لن يستمر طويلا".
وأضاف الرئيس الأوكراني
"فريقنا المفاوض في محادثات بيلاروسيا
ناقش أول خطوة، وهي إعادة الحياة إلى طبيعتها"،
وتابع الرئيس الأوكراني،
إن القوات الروسية دخلت إلى بعض المواقع،
مؤكدا أن هذا الوضع لن يستمر طويلا.
كل الأيام أصبحت متشابهة بطريقة دفاعنا
واستبسالنا وحماية مواطنينا”.
وبينما أعلنت كييف إسقاط مقاتلة روسية
بعد إصابتها بشكل مباشر شمال العاصمة كييف.
ردت روسيا بإعلانها عن تدمير
٥٦مسيرة و٨٢ طائرة حربية أوكرانية
منذ بدء العمليات العسكرية.
(الأحداث والتطورات)
بوتين يدعو دول الجوار لعدم التصعيد ضد موسكو..
ووزارة الدفاع الروسية تبث صورا لتقدم قواتها
في محيط العاصمة كييف..
القوات الروسية تبدأ تطويق كييف وخاركيف،
ويمكن أن تهاجم العاصمة خلال ٢٤ ساعة..
نيويورك تايمز:
١٤طائرة شحن نقلت صواريخ جافلين وقاذفات
الصواريخ ومدافع ثقيلة، إلى مطار قرب الحدود
الأوكرانية،، وكانت هذه الأسلحة عبارة
عن جزء من مبلغ ال٣٥٠ مليون دولار
التي أقرها بايدن لدعم أوكرانيا..
هل يؤدي استهداف محطة زابوريجيا إلى انفجار نووي
الخبراء أكدوا أن الانفجارات في المفاعلات النووية
بحاجة إلى ضربات أكثر تعقيدا ولا تؤثر
هذه الضربات الحالية كالتي تقصف بها
روسيا أوكرانيا،،، لكن هنالك مخاوف
من انتشار الإشعاع النووي، وهذا قد يؤدي
إلى وفاة البشر حولها وإلى أمراض وتشوهات
بشعة كالتي حصلت في التسعينيات
في مفاعل تشيرنوبل..
القوات الأوكرانية تعلن استعادة السيطرة الكاملة على
مدينة غوستوميل شمال كييف،
وتدمير أكثر من ٥١ عربة مدرعة للجيش الروسي،
كما أنها استولت على عدد من الأسلحة
والذخائر كغنيمة ومعظمها في
حالة سليمة بحد قولها،،
بين السيطرة والاستعادة تعيش المدن الأوكرانية
في جو مشتعل من نيران لا تتوقف،
بانتظار الأسوأ في الأيام القادمة!!!
...